[Music]
you are never more alive than when
you're a teenager
your brain is flush with chemicals that
can turn your life into a story of epic
proportions
and yet by the start of my senior year
nothing interesting
had ever happened to me then
something finally happened hi guys come
on in
grace just transferred here from east
river i think you make a truly dynamic
editor-in-chief do you well i'll help
with editing and design just not writing
hey why'd you give up writing i was
asked to write something about someone
really important to me i
just couldn't find the words it's funny
because i can't find the words when i
talk and you can't find the words when
you write
have you ever had a girlfriend no why
not i'm not really good at this stuff
i feel like i don't know anything about
you i used to be good at socializing
what changed nine months ago a car
swerved coming around a bend and
flipped
[Music]
you look um i was gonna say
hot hey grace
just want to say hi and that hope last
night just kind of meant a tiny fraction
to you as it meant to me
that was done the teenage years are
limbo not your mom no
yeah it doesn't matter the world tells
you to express yourself but the minute
that you do it tells you to shut up
just ask her what's going on you're
right i don't know like how i'm supposed
to help i'm messing up henry
okay no it's not when you realize you
can't fix me
what's wrong it's regular stuff you are
not gonna understand we're not regular
people no are you kidding me your
relationship's been perfect since you
were like my age
there is a reason why when every adult
talks about young people they can't
avoid the truth
stop leading me on i'm confused henry i
don't know i know i've known since like
the very beginning
that being young is so painful
it's almost too much to feel
[Music]
[Music]
you